-Our next guest
is a five-time Grammy winner
and Rock and Roll Hall of Famer
who has sold
over 185 million records.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her fantastic new documentary,
"Janet Jackson,"
just premiered
to record ratings,
and you can see
all four hours of it
this Friday at 8:00 p.m.
on Lifetime.
Here is the one,
the only Janet Jackson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi!
Yeah! We love you!
Janet, welcome back!
I love you, bud.
Congrats on the documentary.
"Janet Jackson"
premiered last week.
Huge hit.
Over 15 million people
watched this and loved it.
How does it feel to have it
finally come out?
-My gosh, it --
it feels great.
And I'm so happy.
I'm very thankful
that so many people
watched it and enjoyed it.
-I mean, beyond, beyond, beyond.
It was trending number one
on all the socials.
And I'm like, "Oh,
I cannot wait to watch this."
And then, at the same time,
all of your albums
started going back
on the charts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How crazy is that?
I love that that happened!
I love that that happened.
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was all
such a surprise to me.
I was not expecting any of it.
And with the documentary,
I was just hoping
everyone would enjoy it.
-What made you want
to do a documentary?
-Well, you know, I've --
I've had a career.
I started when I was 7.
It's been almost 50 years
that I've been doing this.
-That's wild.
-And I thought it would be best
to tell my story, if I can,
as opposed to having
someone else tell it for me.
-Yeah.
I mean, that's wild.
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause it feels like --
It's fantastic.
But it does -- in a weird way,
it feels like we've known you.
Because I knew you as Penny
on "Good Times,"
and you go like,
"Oh, yeah, we know Janet."
And then Janet Jackson,
you became Janet Jackson.
And "Rhythm Nation"
and everything.
But then you go, "Oh, wait.
We don't really
know you, know you,"
and know what goes on
in your life and what you were
thinking at the time
or what you were feeling.
And it's like --
To watch this documentary,
it's like, "Oh, my goodness."
This is --
The amount of just pressure
and everything that goes into
every single aspect of your life
and career and relationships.
It's --
Is it therapeutic
to get it out there?
-It -- ooh!
It was --
It was definitely therapeutic.
It was difficult, at times,
to talk about.
But it --
it definitely was therapeutic.
And it took five years to --
to make.
-Wow.
-And I was just really so --
so worried that people
would find it boring,
to be quite honest with you.
My favorite episode
is the first --
the very first episode,
because it talks about
my brothers and going back to
that time period and my family.
And that's the episode I enjoy.
And then everything else
related to myself, I was like,
"Oh, my gosh, they're gonna
think this is so boring."
I'm just happy everyone
enjoyed it and got to see it.
-Was it difficult
to pick different memories
and moments
and finding old footage,
never-before-seen footage,
And you're like,
"Should I release that?
Should I not?"
I mean, you went for it.
-It was difficult
'cause there was so much --
so much to pick from.
I mean, every tour,
even when I was a kid,
documenting everything.
So it was -- it's hard to tell
your story in four hours.
It's a very difficult
thing to do.
-Yeah. You did it.
-But we managed
to get a good amount in.
-Then you got to go back to your
hometown, to Gary, Indiana,
which you haven't been --
You guys have to see this.
It's amazing.
I mean, did you get chills?
Was it weird?
What was it like?
-I -- I loved it.
I hadn't been there
since I was 8.
And just everyone in the
neighborhood, they welcomed us.
I went to my brothers'
and sisters' high school
and spent time with the kids
at the school for a minute.
-They must have been thrilled.
-It was just such
a wonderful feeling.
And to know that we all
shared that house
and how small it was.
-Yeah, when you're a kid,
it seems giant.
-Just incredible for me.
-Yeah.
There's so many things I learned
about you in this documentary,
but one is that
you were going to go to --
you wanted to go
to Pepperdine University
and study business law.
-Yeah.
-And then your dad's like,
"No, you're going into
show business."
What dad says, "No,
you're not going to college"?
You say that in the documentary.
Like, "Who says that?"
-Yeah. Well, you know, everyone
being in show business,
it wouldn't be so bad to be an
entertainment attorney, I guess.
-Yeah, you're right.
-Still keeping it
within the family.
-Yeah.
Quest is actually in -- in the
documentary, as well, talking.
How important was it for you
to put him in?
And did he pressure you?
-Hey!
[ Laughter ]
-No!
No pressure at all.
It was very important for me to
have Quest in the documentary.
He played a big part in such
a huge moment in my life.
He was a huge supporter
in getting me inducted
into the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame,
along with all the fans.
And I just
can't thank him enough.
I mean, that's a huge moment
in my career, in my life.
-He loves you so much,
as we all do.
But he really, really,
really loves you, yeah.
Yeah, he's a fan.
He loves you.
[ Applause ]
At the end of the documentary,
there's a snippet of some
new music called "Love I Love."
And my question is --
I know, I know, I know.
You're like, "Why?
Don't ask me this."
But are we going to get to hear
the song, the whole thing?
And is this hinting
at something?
What's next?
Tell me something.
-It's so funny because that's --
that's --
It was a song that I recorded
like three years ago.
And in the documentary,
we thought,
"Oh, this would be cool
to put this song right here
at this moment,
this piece in the documentary."
And everyone
started reacting to it.
So, I don't know.
We'll just have to see.
Maybe it'll be a --
You know, we'll see.
-Is there other unreleased
Janet stuff that we --
like "Love I Love"
that we might see?
Oh, I know -- don't ask.
[ Laughter ]
-I've recorded so many songs
that I've never released.
So, we'll see.
-Wow.
Okay, we'll see.
[ Applause ]
I want to thank you
for doing our show.
You know we love you.
Whenever you're in town,
we want to see you.
And I want to give you
a big hug.
Congrats on this documentary
and on everything.
We're the biggest fans of you
over here, so thank you.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
It's always a pleasure
being with you guys.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Janet Jackson
in her documentary,
"Janet Jackson."
Take a look.
♪ People of the world today ♪
♪ Are we looking
for a better way of life ♪
♪ We are a part
of the Rhythm Nation ♪
-And it was a big night
for Janet Jackson last night.
She picked up her first-ever
Grammy and became
the first woman nominated
for Producer of the Year.
♪♪
-You didn't feel like,
"Oh, my God.
Like, she's preaching to us."
It was dope.
-Yeah, it was.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Janet Jackson, everybody!
You can see all four hours
of the documentary,
"Janet Jackson,"
this Friday at 8:00 p.m.
on Lifetime
or online at mylifetime.com.